megan alors mégane c'est nouveau coup
dur pour megan cette fois ci elle est
lâché par netflix c'est vrai ça avant
oui absolument elle avait signé au
moment où tout allait bien pour mettre
flics ça on est pendant la période du
coronavirus les abonnés arrive par
millions et netflix a signé énormément
de contrat et là ils viennent de se
séparer d'un contrat qui s'appelait paul
c'était un dessin animé on peut dans
lequel mégane est bien traité un peu
c'est très un petit personnage animé et
qui devait marquer ça elle devait
rencontrer les grandes figures qui ont
marqué un peu un peu sa vie et bien on
vient d'apprendre que ce contrat là en
effet n'aurait pas lieu c'est parce que
vous regardez ça ils savent que
maintenant il ya dix ans qu'ils en
savent peu marre de ces stars qui
tu verrais sa tête de peter morgan ou
lorient lui j'ai je suis désolé mais
alors si je puis me permettre ils ont
tous le même taille ou contador c'est
bien malheureux
100 millions d'euros oui je suis
d'accord qui a été dit les en trois
paiements il sera chez tran cas jusqu'à
maintenant mais olwin alors ne concerne
pas pour le coup ce documentaire port
elle sait qu'on concernant wii pour vous
documenter un deuxième documentaire
invictus ouhlala tu l'as du grand prix
et d'autres en cours aussi bien
évidemment d'ailleurs sur les femmes se
c'est très simple il vous restait qu'une
barre a été annulé oui tout à fait mais
c'était un projet aussi qu'elle avait
avec david furnish et donc les marinas
eugène voilà faux pas des autres
si vous permettez d'ailleurs que vous
avez entendu à ce que tu manges elton
john d'ailleurs qui est qui qui nous a
relaté
le sergent est tout à fait lorsqu on
s'est rencontrés alors il n'arrêtait pas
ce qui effectivement il est resté dix
jours ils thon rouge non mais ça va je
crois que vous l'avez beaucoup marqué
dans cette rencontre
abbey s'est passé quelque chose s'est
passé quelque chose alors écoutez je
n'irai vous
écouter et la nati cents contre un
artiste il parle d' artistique
c'était à la sympathique baisse avait
besoin enfin quelqu'un qui confirme là
ça va bien faire fermer un monsieur qui
me croyais pas ces gens résident janvier
il envie de revenir ici comme je te
préviens c'est des petits poucets
norbourg alors donc effectivement alors
ça c'est très important c'est jean
michel qui avait soulevé le lièvre à
l'époque netflix trouvait chercher sa
kate middleton pour l'as la suite de la
série de crohn est pas qu ils ont enfin
trouvé brittany dixon alors c'est qui
amène photo est là il est australienne
brittany et elle ressemble le plus ce
quartier voilà qui est kate middleton
mattani dans le nord fricker semble
quand même la ressemblance est
troublante
alors j'ai fait quelques recherches qui
est incroyable elle a une c'est encore
une petite soeur qui ressemble
étrangement je vous assure à kippa pippa
pippa middleton ont laissé se redresse
où elle passait toutes ses vacances à
londres à la visite est quasiment toutes
les résidences royales et sachez quand
même que lé très elle fait la charité
elle fait du bénévoles travaillent
bénévolement pour l'hôpital de la petite
ville
elle a décompté dans le christ il
entraîne sa vente comme le vrai la reine
leur est agréé pour le bras très bien à
l'arrêt ne l'aurait pas forcément adorer
puisque justement le fait qu'elle soit
australienne avec un accent assez fort
va être très compliqué et alors le fait
que justement la couronne ait démenti
justement l'appréciation de ressemblance
je suis deuxième à la reine leur ai
adoré parce que vous voyez à l'été
austral à l'orgue et puisqu'elle était
judicieux
si il n'y avait en référendum
aujourd'hui probablement que les
statistiques nous disent que les
australiens se séparait de la couronne
britannique est là pour le coup elle
annoncé
non mais lol
oui tout à fait puisque j'ai eu
l'occasion de travailler donc pour une
famille de la noblesse qui est dans la
cour on en avait changé bien peu près
donc le but de
ces barrages de fortune info d'avoir de
la reine d'angleterre est effectivement
non cette kate middleton ne sera à mon
avis à mon sens pas du tout à ce rappel
un couple est alors plus qu il ya quand
même un gros problème dans la série
parce que si on arrive aux années 2000
je vous rappelle de la rencontre n'est
pas en 2000 mais en 2001 et juste pour
se parler donc si on reprend les faits
des dates aussi cela oui mais là si vous
vous souvenez je l'avais quand elle a 17
ans je vous adore mais peut-être vous
déjà leur ensemble
j'ai une question pour vous mais je n'ai
posture mais a surnagé question pour
vous comme tout le temps en angleterre à
sec dans cette émission notamment
bertrand on a pris parti je reconnais
tape un peu sur megan est ce que vous
êtes plutôt d'accord avec notre opinion
sur mégane depuis le début et celle de
bertrand mais pas du tout parce que
excusez moi
vous m'aiderez mégane non mais c'est pas
une question d'adorer non mais moi je
n'attends pas partie jeune homme espère
la prochaine partie simplement vous êtes
en train de me monter kate comme si
c'était la sainte nitouche du siècle
elle et moi enfin sa réputation n'était
plus à faire c'est quand même fait sauf
naître barre et alcool et je vous
rappelle qu'elle était avec un étudiant
en droit vous pouvez confirmer leurs
oeufs et vous aller me promener il dira
le contraire seulement non mais c'est
très bien qu'elle était avec un étudiant
en droit et dont la changer d'école
quand même pour rencontrer le professeur
a été programmé pour être ré notamment
parce que ça sa mère carole était
machiavélique
c'est carole fait l'instrument c'est
carole oui mais attendez la vie n'est
pas stupide non plus à la soneb et
découvrir le droit que c'est de
simplement vu ça mettrait bac seul n'est
qu'apparence compte on est en monarchie
et qu'elle fait le job divinement voilà
ce que je dis je
n'est plus à l'est mais pour attaquer
mais galilée mais gary 16 h du matin
votre avis c'est aussi l'avis de la
monarchie britannique puisque vous êtes
là bas près d'eux et donc vous qu'on va
vous communiquez vous êtes prêt de et
vous avez vraiment on va dire l'oreille
qui traîne et ce qui se dit là bas et
notamment un jour peut-être sur le
jubilé ça c'est intéressant le 2 juin
les festivités du jubilé commence alors
dans quel état sera la reine parce que
bertrand la semaine dernière luzech elle
est plutôt en bonne santé c'est ça et
qu'elle sera debout en tout cas ne sera
là en tout cas elle sera elle sera
larrouy elle sera là voilà on espère
bien qu'elle sera debout et donc elle
sera là et debout parce que c'est parce
que vous avez dit alors excusez moi oh
merde oui
d'accord mais alors là c'est d'accord je
je je suis un peu perplexe elle est
spécialisée dans la couronne elle sera
couché selon faut être assise à laurier
a pas là alors vous n'avez peut-être pas
regarder le communiqué du palais hier
guy l'allier que tout est gardé à deux
parties sont annulés je vous rappelle
qu'ils ont quand même acheté un
sarcophage similaire à celui de michael
jackson peut lui donner de l'air pascal
a de gros problèmes respiratoires
donc je le moment ce que j'ai vu ce
qu'on peut peut-être dire c'est que le
jubilé arrive en plein milieu de ces
garden party je pense simplement qu'elle
va se reposer la reine à cayenne à 16
ans il lui faut du sarcophage voulez
vous que ça moi je n'ai pas match est
vrai et ce qui se dit c'est que c'est
comme donner la première mais qu'on la
verra dans un fauteuil roulant mais
laissés en très mauvaise santé ah oui
après on peut en échange et si vous
voulez en débatte ya aucun problème en
discuter c'est mignon comme d aimer va
vous pensez qu'elle en bonne santé moi
alors ça n'engage que moi je pense
qu'elle ne sera pas en fauteuil roulant
vous savez quand on aura la réponse
toutes les propagandes roulant la
cérémonie c'est pas une question
d'accord c'est dans quel état elle est
aujourd'hui la létalité et les drm en
fauteuil roulant car il est invité c'est
une info ciel elle sait aujourd'hui
comment le 2 juin elle courra dans un
jardin
jusqu'à lors des obsèques il ya eu des
coupures et des peintres et on la voit
marcher pour le coup elle est pas du
tout oui mais tout à coup l'un des
montages sont pas là des 10 il s'avance
il paraît que kate et william en eau
forêt interdite saab ou le ski s'est dit
en angleterre ou interdit leur présence
au balcon de buckingham et que c'est non
négociable et que la reine a dit oui
c'est vrai ça exactement c'est
incroyable cette histoire c'est à dire
qu'il ya vraiment un problème entre les
deux irait conciliables il ya eu un
problème de racisme que vous connaissez
très bien et qui est réel fondés merci
donc j'ai gardé pas mal n'aura pas droit
d'aller sur le balcon non tout ça parce
que justement mégane est persona non
grata parce que une femme une seule a
décidé que c'était la femme à abattre et
vous vous la portée aux nues commercial
alors là moi je suis désolé c'est parce
qu'il n' y un mais vous savez ça qu'on
est interdite de balcons qu'elles
étaient interdites de balcon alors là
j'avoue non je ne sais pas si ça peut
faire du tournoi c'est en belgique que
cette fois la monarchie mais ce n'est
qu'en surtout de voir ce qui va se
passer et mathieu pour le couple si vous
savez ceux qui disent qu'ils savent
beaucoup tu es certain beaucoup mais
dans la brousse
vous n'êtes rien parce que ces
personnels d'agencés de gibier sans
regardé par le monde entier n'est pas si
j'avais dû il était à terre du balcon
parce qu'elle voulait venir son balcon
avec une équipe de netflix qui l'a filmé
5 balcon que ces terres de netflix et du
coup et c'était ça ou rien et du couvent
de vie passé rien ne me dérange pas ça
c'est palace que le génie point de vue
images du monde la semaine dernière sur
meghan markle et sur harry il était le
temps était très réservé sur le fond 1
c'est bien pour ça qu'on a un
spécialiste qu'est ce qu'il ya c'est la
communication et pour veut savoir c'est
à dire que moi je suis enthousiaste j'ai
eu la chance de partir avec un
photographe chris noth est donc oui sauf
make up qui m'accompagnent dans tous mes
déplacements je vous avais proposé
justement la lecture de cet article sur
le suivi des gal et harry donc on a
suivi à los angeles n'a pas lu l'article
et paito qu'on n'a pas eu le temps ce
jeu déjà prouvé l'existence de matinée
mais réelle alors alors je j'ai une
question posée aussi parce que ça c'est
l'impôt que j'ai lu aussi donc c'est
intéressant de voir toutes les rumeurs
et d'avoir les réponses aujourd'hui
c'est pour ça qu'on veut venir deux
personnes parce que le jubilé sera
regardée à peu près autant parait-il que
les paires bolland est en médiatisés par
don que le super bowl c'est vous dire si
ça intéresse les gens il aurait été pas
mal de grandes personnalités du monde
qui aurait boycotté la cérémonie parmi
lesquels barack obama en solidarité avec
megan alors c'est incroyable il a
décliné effectivement avec l'ue
l'invitation barack obama mais vous
imaginez d'arles et obama quand même qui
représente la mixité la mixité un
renouveau mondiale internationaux
vous croyez qu'il va accepter le racisme
exactement la même mariage surtout un
vous saviez ça qu'elle est ce selon le
code de sorte que paris de barack obama
puisque on peut peut-être dire aussi
c'est que ça commence tout bientôt le 15
mai c'est tom cruise pour le coup qui va
présider une grande cérémonie en grand
spectacle dans lequel il va y avoir
énormément de chevaux aux assistants au
château de windsor
tom cruise ci qui est un coup ça c'est
génial qu'alors et écouter
on veut de la font le pari
nations occidentales et potentiellement
prévu qu'il vienne 1 et il ne viendra
plus
selon ce témoin de quelle année c'est le
jubilé de quelle année il ya cinq ans
donc quand même bon ce même après on en
vit à rien ça se trouve ça se trouve
c'est pas ma tête la musique vous savez
au casino mais je dis pas que je remets
pas en question mais ya pris aucune
certitude que vous c'est vous qui avez
raison et paraît écoutez moi je reviens
de londres après c'est comment vous avez
ces infos lui reviennent mais sur son ca
le nounours on travaille pour tapis
rouge pour plein de magazines différents
diverses télévision la bbc fort la bbc
d'accord et on accompagne là on
accompagne et andrew l'autre jour donc
dans ses déplacements pour la couronne
le prince andrew oui le prince oui oui
non l'ucad à barcelone des classes que
derrière ce rôle carlos à renoncer pour
y échanger avec le prince andrew mais
bien évidemment c'est à dire qu'on a
passé quand même qu'un appel a fait donc
que d'être la personne fait ce qui amène
à croire et blême et elle a posé les
bars où vous savez qu il représente bien
évidemment la reine puisqu'elle a
délégué normes aimant et là où je j'ai
l'impression différé voilà exactement et
d'ailleurs qui sera à son bras mais non
et qui appelle à s'entraider pas altesse
royale on est d'accord
quesada son bras pour le verser dans la
vision bras pour le jubilé et qui est
quand même le personnage le plus élevé
oui mais la reine abdique référé si
c'est la pression que ça maintenant plus
ou moins j'ai la plus envisagée d'or
avec la reine parce que c'est pas
possible autrement de pour avoir des
informations
lors du jubilé effectivement lequel des
deux belles comment ils accepter autant
mais ils font exprès de brouiller les
pistes bien victoire tant d'informations
dit c'est à dire que les informations
viennent de différents médias vous le
savez malheureusement après il faut les
distiller ensuite moi je préfère les
informations du palais que les
informations des médias et donc si vos
sources sont internet soit merde c'est
quoi ces problèmes c'est quoi votre
question sur place mais qui ne sont pas
les mêmes que monsieur mais comment est
ce que j'aimerais comprendre c'est
comment y ressemble
c'est andrew qui ouvre à la réalité
non drogba l'autre il y a énormément
son
contraire vous le savez traité c'est pas
tout ils sont contents chers amis vous
serez très bien je vais je comprends
bien que vous privilégiez vos
informations par rapport aux miennes
mais pas hésité l'ombre d'un doute cette
année
d'août valeur croyez moi si on prend vos
informations les miennes on n'y arrive
pas et ce qu'on avait bien compris vous
savez je lui prends relativement vite
non
[Musique]
est-ce qu'on va prier meurtre de kurt
pour cette chronique je ne sais pas si
j'osais pas sûr qu'ils viennent
s'énervait pourquoi parce que vous avez
trouvé le spécialiste mais demain on va
bientôt avant l'événement
[Applaudissements]
combien quelque chose le spécialiste bio
n'a qu'un monsieur est un comédien
c'était un piège aujourd'hui juste pour
tag à 6
[Applaudissements]
m
manqué
[Applaudissements]
on nous dira renault duval selon mes
moyens mais j'ai vu que j'étais leur jeu
en revanche je tiens à préciser que
coûte et le 80% de mes infos son vrai
nom du sacro-saint
c'est une connerie monstrueuse mais le
reste avec ça et moi je dois je l'adoré
c'est ben apparemment
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
on est on est dedans on se met d'accord
mis sur mon ami ah oui je suis inquiet
avait des victimes andrew n'ouvrira pas
dire que la n va très bien a
effectivement cannes en fait des bruits
de balcons en mixant la santé de la
reine il faut être très honnête non son
réseau la santé de la maman sans être
désagréable alors direct la santé de la
reine ne va pas j'adore cette séquence
on remercie monsieur bravo et merci
vraiment
un comédien
y a pas manqué
tous les côtés
tu reviens cette bretelle pour bien
faire merci
beaucoup c'est pas sûr de revenir à
cette prochaine